okay let's talk next about some notable
stories that the david pakman show
subreddit the david pakman show
subreddit now has more than 16,000 of
our viewers and listeners subscribed you
can discuss topics from the show or
other topics of political interest with
other viewers and listeners there are
moderators things are kept under control
don't worry about trolling david
pakman.com slash reddit is the place one
discussion I wanted to address was
posted this morning or a few days ago
actually not this morning and it the
question is will David endorse or at
least disclose the candidate he supports
a caller today asked who David would
vote for if the primary were today and
he responded with either Bernie or
Warren but will David make either a
formal endorsement or at least an
official announcement of who he intends
to vote for so I've gotten a lot of
emails from people who say they want me
to disclose to make an endorsement soon
and others who say David you've made
clear that you are a Bernie Warren guy
it doesn't really make sense to throw in
who you're going to vote for at this
early stage it's better for you to just
keep reporting on policy and whatever
here's my plan I am going to tell you
who I support in the primary here in the
state of Massachusetts now I want to be
transparent I expect that by the time I
vote in Massachusetts we will know
whether Bernie or Warren which of the
two if either has a shot at securing the
nomination so I don't think that it is
going to be a crucial moment at that
point anymore but quite frankly the
reason I'm not saying who I'm going to
vote for is I don't know I'm a Bernie
Warren guy there are lots of reasons why
I am more inline with Bernie than
Elizabeth Warren I have some concerns
about some of the elements in Bernie's
campaign and I also think about what is
most likely to be made policy there's a
pragmatic element these are not attacks
on either candidate I don't actually
know who it is that I'm going to vote
for here in Massachusetts but I will
tell you rest assured another post from
the David Pakman show subreddit Dave
Rubin I am now pro-life yes there
a cultural critic and arbiter of ideas
named Dave Rubin who interviews people
from all over the political spectrum
mostly right-wingers and he has talked
about how he didn't leave the left the
left left him but his views have
actually been changing and the latest in
this evolution is that he now says that
he is no longer an atheist and I saw a
video where he said he's still mostly
secular but believes there's something
bigger and it seemed like a way to
basically ride the fence so that you
don't have to in a completely
embarrassing way say my view has changed
180 degrees which for a 40 year old to
have that kind of Awakening is is odd is
to say the least but he claims he's had
it fine he's found a way to ride the
fence which is to say he's still mostly
secular but he now believes that there
is something bigger and that it seems
like it'll kind of placate the the right
wing of religious folks that
increasingly follow him and so the
prediction here from this user on our
subreddit is Dave Rubin will eventually
come out as pro-life and being against
abortion wouldn't be surprised if it'd
be funnier if he came out and said he
was no longer gay that that actually
would be more of an awakening but I
don't expect that to happen and I would
not be shocked if he comes out and says
he is now pro-life also from the David
Pakman show subreddit Pete Buddha jej
releases a list of McKinsey clients and
that list includes blook Blue Cross Blue
Shield of Michigan and the Department of
Defense so listen I've already said that
Pete Budaj is not a progressive he's
really a Biden centrist that's what he
is he's not been hiding it his views on
campaign finance reform are not
particularly progressive we had video of
that for you earlier this week I think
that it's perfectly fine to say part of
Pete Buddha judge not being a
progressive is that he once consulted
for the Department of Defense what is
less progressive than that or for an
insurance company but I actually don't
think these are the strongest arguments
against Buddha judge in the same way
that you know we talked earlier this
week how there are people going after
Elizabeth Warren because she consulted
with a lot of different companies over a
30-year period earning
1.9 million dollars over those 30 years
and there are people saying well this
client was not good or that client was
not good lawyers consultants I mean I'm
not defending them but you don't always
love every client that you're working
with maybe he does love the Department
of Defense or those insurance companies
I don't know but there are so many other
reasons not to support BP to judge that
I don't know that it's necessary to go
down this path if you disagree let me
know join the discussion on the David
Pakman show
subreddit at david pakman.com slash re d
di t